[Music]
you know I know a little
something-something okay I remember the
big pants the tube tops
I remember girl calm I remember just I
remember limited to the biggest one that
comes to my mind is like wearing your
jeans backwards I may have tried it once
like a load in my bedroom but otherwise
had never had the balls to go out of the
house like that oh dear I love this the
swag kind of look like somebody's dead
but he's cool he got a little money
first of all let's talk about his pants
they appear to be about ten sizes too
big like what were they thinking oh my
god what is this I feel like I'm doing
like a PBS special on this set Oh what
is this
[Applause]
oh my god love super soakers so lame I'm
an adult I pay taxes I have car
insurance what am i crying
I always all the neighbor kids had them
and I always wanted one and I was
jealous and give it is and now all I
want to do is run around and squirt
people as a kid I loved like playing
like tag or just like I don't even know
what you would call a game we would just
kind of run around and like hide and
then shoot each other I had some really
weenie little water guns but I always
wanted something like this I watched
every commercial for this it's like you
know before Sims came out that was dream
lies make new friends choose lifestyle
sports hang out work make your fashion
[Music]
and I remember this weird cartoon oh I
didn't get it cuz you know my parents
like why you need to create a life if
you invite you got a good life which I
did have a good life you know he's your
pants I was just really hoping like mom
and dad would come through on like a
birthday or Christmas pretty sure I did
ask for the big ones like every year and
I never got it what's up mom so it's
just something that I really wanted cuz
it was like about a girl a new life I'm
figuring it out
friends and I was a little girl to time
so most the time hanging out with my
friends was like playing outside with my
sister not kissing cute boys and going
to prom and all that stuff like
PlayStation she was coming for you
PlayStation look at it Nintendo she was
coming for you that's why you killed her
yes I don't read instructions it's
almost a status symbol of like how big
your Super Soaker was but like you can
rule the neighborhood if you had the
biggest one but I was kind of a
pipsqueak so I probably couldn't handle
it anyway I think I was too distracted
like buying Star Wars action figures to
like save up enough money to buy myself
an actual Super Soaker which that's
probably the saddest sentence I've ever
said I'm $250 I'm rich it was not
expecting this I thought we were talking
about awful clothes I'm ready to like
get out more clothes to for the time
period that it was in it's actually a
pretty well like a pretty well-made game
it's still just because I wanted it so
much as a kid it just still gives me
that gooey feeling of like wow now that
I'm an adult
I don't worry about go in a class or
signing up for activities or you know
all the stuff that all these girls are
worried about so it kind of makes me
nostalgic of the time period I used to
be oh I'm totally gonna my room it's
gonna look at me like I'm crazy like
you're an adult like we just went to the
club last week and you're sitting here
crying while you're talking to Josephine
about her pajamas and it'll be great
news for my therapist though all right
test shot
oh that's got some good distance on it I
win I mean that was really satisfying
spring Troy I fit he never actually got
me I'm making myself more wet from the
gun itself just leaking but it's okay
[Music]
you